it's been a decade since Iraq's last
provincial election many people say
they're looking forward to seeing a
change in their daily lives we will have
preventional
councils which will elect
Governors which can get benefit from the
financial budget of the
governorate which means that controlling
the governor rates means that
controlling the Parliamentary the
results of the next parliamentary
elections millions of Iraqis are
eligible to vote in 2019 provincial
councils were dissolved due to the
demands of protesters criticizing
systematic failures and Corruption now
concerns over transparency are prompting
many to question The credibility of the
elections but the main election body
says it will preserve the Integrity we
registered more than uh
uh International Observer uh and uh we
issued the budges for them that would
allow them to enter the polling centers
uh we hope they'll participate widely uh
in this elections the country's largest
political group The sest Movement is
boycotting the election in 2021 it
secured the largest Block in the
parliament but failed to form a
government political deadlock was
followed by another wave of violence
that ended with the sadrist resigning
from Parliament now the leader Mt s
wants to delegitimize the system and is
calling on his supporters not to
vote the sadis movement decided to
boycott the election to voice its
rejection of the government's policies
the boycott is to deprive the government
of
legitimacy with many political movements
in Iraq a boycott could instead be seen
as a vot of confidence in the very
system it aims to challenge a good good
reason for the government to encourage a
high turnout the rest of Iraq's
mainstream political factions are
throwing the weight behind candidates
outet speaker Muhammad Hali is seeking
to secure a clear win within Sunni
majority provinces as a show of force
following a Supreme Court decision to
end his term in office Iran back Chia
factions are desperate for public
validation through their candidates
after the protests in 2009
diminished the support Ali Hashim Al
jaaz Bagdad